all right four people joining this
livestream we are looking at some
integration of wiki data into of
language and it isn't as good as what we
have but it's useful because has all
kinds of random things all right let's
take a look here um okay so I should
look at okay but but this these things
will be system symbols right they will
not need the graph store context yes
the forth symbols that we want to review
today they should become system why
didn't they turn black here that
requires to prototype so far okay should
I just use the prototype build yes I
shall only start up there we go
something's happening is it dying on
startup no it seemed to work okay um so
here let's read that as a prototype okay
so wait a minute so if I say needs graph
store here
no it's still blue this is the prototype
built so what's going on no wait a
minute
why does that say that this is supposed
to be the prototype build don't tell me
six five one one five nine five alpha
goodness sake okay could somebody get
hold of Roger find out what happened to
my prototype build anybody here could do
that do I have to do it
I know I know no we need a better method
than that Oh check this out
portrait managers
there's no better man sit okay I'll do
it myself then hold on let me put this
on mute
you
all right I think I have a solution here
okay there we go all right so what
happens if I don't give a max items here
you'll get maybe 50 results up till 50
so what are all these different Albert's
as am I seeing kind of the garbage of
what's in wiki data well there might be
a music album or movie or other things
that are named after this physicist no I
see so when we give and by the way why
is this boldface that wouldn't be
boldface for our own entity would it the
entities are salida different they are
balled on input and later less bold okay
so that we should copy that we shouldn't
have these be bold why would we have
these be bold but the other ones are not
yes also there's a link to this sign
document that makes some suggestions but
okay do we have a designer here they
have designer who made this design who
made this design okay so let's get hold
of whoever made this design was it Chris
bellies somebody really short okay so
let's please get him on this call you
know let me do that okay yes I do
so we simply have been discussing some
interesting questions so how to exactly
style them and why for instance should
the label replace the ID or should it
shown in addition to the ID I mean this
person went to a couple iterations let's
wait till we have a designer yeah okay
well okay maybe we can keep looking at
these things okay okay let's look at the
these pages so this is a pretty
all functions similar 20 D value but
this some additional and some other
functions that are not there for
instance wiki data data does not do
caching because an editor might usually
want the latest value they just entered
and we killed it oh that's not a good
argument I think there should be an
option to cache that's a silly argument
the fraction of people editing is tiny
compared to the fashion of people using
okay a bit of time scare do you want to
kiss I don't know let's give it let's
put a parameter in there I mean you know
what's the how do we do caching how do
we specify caching for you know entity
prefetch has a has a mechanism and then
it has time to live right
alpha knows or sends information how
long data well it should be cached
Nikita doesn't of course not of course
not but I mean caching it for an hour
right if you're you just a user or not
an editor you absolutely want it cached
am I making sense yep then now all might
slice them but it's just silly to not
cache it I mean for the sake of the
point zero zero one percent of people
who might be editing right that's a
wrong decision I mean I'm not often
convinced isn't not kind of the natural
continuation of this that import and
related things would catch all the
things oh no no no no this is supposed
to be some kind of knowledge-based thing
I mean the right it's not it's not
supposed to be something okay why is
this in some huge font here that seems
wrong that's just a minor mistake but
somebody needs to fix it there should
have been a project manager in this in
this some meeting I really don't like
doing these without that but anyway
whatever so can somebody make a note of
that please or do I have to go send that
in nobody could do okay
B do you still know okay
all right so this is like entity value
you said mmm-hmm so why is it not called
wiki data value that's an interesting
question that also someone at the
conference brought up says and so we
have two ways of naming functions one
that names the object that goes in and
then calls it value say date value and
other functions like coordinate chart
data and in this case it's more like the
service that we are using is in the
first argument so that's why the data
fraction makes more sense okay what is
all of this stuff it's a rich data model
and this allows controlling some of
those things and in other cases allows
or describes how you can query things so
this is all in this page okay and do we
have presumably we have some monitoring
system for the wiki data Sparkle
endpoint so that if it goes down we
produce a message that's reasonable that
doesn't just say that doesn't just you
know disgorge random internal code yes
or so they fail your object that is
returned from our URL utilities is
passed through so can interested users I
can investigate what happened yeah look
we need siscon to monitor this endpoint
if we're going to be using it right they
should write a test for that endpoint
and if that fails it should do something
making sense yes rather than it I mean
are we proc seeing this or are we going
is it going direct this is going to the
life Mickey data's Portland point okay
but we're not proxying that connection
no okay okay
each item what is Q 2 or P 31 is that
clear to us Earths
those are those are wiki data entity and
property identifier I see
Anthony's RQ something properties RP
something I would use a better a longer
number here because it will be more less
obscure and by the way in this
you should put those in italics the NNN
okay um I love the item the description
of the item so okay but there are many
different properties which would be
supported by so this raw wiki des so for
the property I can give the raw wiki
data identify as a string or I can give
an external identifier object correct
correct and these are ones that are
built in guaranteed to be supportive is
that correct yes
what is this external identifier types
what is that another symbol that we
should review those are the possible
first arguments of external identifier
it's just a variable just like services
I see okay so that's so right now okay
do these other ones work all of them do
work yes mr. Mickey date that's good
don't we want this to be capital a in
depth
case noise so each of them is very
carefully chosen
I think that's inconsistent with how
service connect refers darkish that
doesn't mean that service connect got it
right that's that's true I think we
capitalize the first letter and that's
just the way it is I think so too
um okay I think we should do that anyway
okay so great so then these so okay so
let's talk about so each one of these if
I pick I assume I can't pick a random so
how much of the entity stuff works on
these each entity that we can map to a
wiki data ID no no I didn't mean that I
mean I meant on these the functions so
if this is external identifier of how do
I get an external identifier for
something well you start typing let's
say ISBN you know and then read it off
your book for instance okay all right
fine but I mean I don't have a book here
so but then also if you have a wiki data
item you can ask for an ISBN ten using
big data data okay so let's say how do I
get so okay let's try the Bible then an
entity for us let's hope that's an
entity for us Oh unless this is totally
broken is this totally broken this the
prototype build is this not able to
let's try another thing I don't know if
that's okay
hmm well that might have been a bug okay
so let's try then I can say I spent n
here yes and I get nothing
so if I do yeah that could have two
reasons either we don't have to be good
at IT mapping or wicked data doesn't
have T okay so if I say properties I get
nothing as well so that's not good
but but what true temp shouldn't we get
a list of properties from where he data
didn't I just wait if we had wiki data
alignment but you picked an entity that
we don't have wiki data alignment for we
don't have the bodies but wait a minute
there are no there's no properties thing
there either where is that there is
currently no properties okay so we
should have one of those because we have
that for everything else and that should
be a synonym for all but do you do you
mean they just e identifies for the
properties or do you mean the actual
values I assume I mean proper that
whatever this does all properties which
means it just means give me values for
all available that's not right
that's not what we do for other entities
right if I say this I'm sorry
no I I know that but but most entities I
do this and I say properties I may get
the properties that yes like that makes
sense okay so we should do the same
thing here and I don't know what this
means because if this is giving values
that's not the right thing right yes I
mean it should if that's I don't even
know what it's how it would return those
so you usually use it in the combination
of the key data data then your item then
constants non identify your properties
comma dataset okay I I don't think
that's the name that we should have for
that but it's not consistent with what
we do elsewhere so what's this gonna do
okay so this is gonna give a whole bunch
of what the heck is that
oh that's it that's a property value
which seems not very useful here because
not telling me what property has that
value right yes so this seems like a
kind of useless thing to return I mean
no it's if we're doing this using up all
to do this seems wrong right unless
there's a description no and the entity
external identifier contains no
information about which property this is
hey whoever's typing our ear could you
stop all right please so sorry ideas
that you rather would use a more
descriptive format let's say Association
or data set in a second argument if you
want what we say data set for in this
case right if we're doing wherever it
was right if we have this here we
already have a whole mechanism for this
right so we should just reuse it if you
say data set here right we get this yes
in the same text for Niki data data and
the second argument data set okay fine
fine okay but I don't know what this is
but I think it's wrong I think
properties it should do the exact same
thing that properties does here which is
just give a list of properties okay
makes sense and then if you want to
decorate that with identifier properties
and non identifier properties no quite
understand what that means
so that means properties that we have
built-in right no it is rather Viki data
has about over 6,000 properties and
4,000 of them are identifiers external
identifier their external identifies
that means sometimes you don't care
about them okay so on our live stream by
the way points out that some properties
have freshness associated with them
which would give time to live
information by making sense
I'm not aware of that but I can look
into it look at what why don't we look
here we should be able to clear that out
here okay what is this supposed to mean
so this is an implicit list of items can
be specified okay what does this have to
do with anything what's the type here
entity type or an external identifier
okay oh please don't have things where
there's a big long four line explanation
here come on we know we know we're not
supposed to do that yeah I thought hard
how to write dead okay do you really
need me to help I'm sure I don't need to
help you can you can write short here
and then you write it afterwards in some
longer form yes that seems very wrong
okay sure we can give more than one
example in basic examples for a function
with this much information in it yes
okay but so here what we obviously need
to do right is that presumably there's a
mapping so what is the status of the
mapping from our entities to wiki data
entities there's there's a lot of it and
we're constantly updating those I mean I
have one thing I just noticed is there's
I think there's still some holes where
we have Wikipedia alignment and we
haven't filled in the wiki data IDs like
your some of your book examples before
where we have Wikipedia alignment and we
just need to we can we can
programmatically get the mapping to wiki
data and fill in those IDs okay so
unlike a value this is returning a list
yes by the way I just did one thing I
told you to a drag select across this
thing and it fail
so that needs to be reported in the
project at that time it worked but the
previous time and when I dragged
selected across the thing that was that
entity it refused to do the drag select
if you could put up a message here about
yes something
okay so we're mate so the the value is
given analyst here why is that in
general there can be multiple values
claimed by different sources or
sometimes that ultimately multiple
values like okay but but I think that's
probably wrong in general right because
if we if you're gonna use this like a an
entity property value thing you don't
want that list we have a third argument
for entity value that specifies whether
to decorate in ways like that right so
but in the example of population of a
city should that always be a single
value yes because you should always a
single value just like it is for our
entity property value system right
always be a single value a code won't
work right but there's no mechanic way
of determining better a property should
have a single or list value and that
uncertainty makes it later on harder to
your crystal values okay but we're not
it's not gonna work if we're gonna have
this video analog of entity property
it's not gonna work to return values in
a list so how we can deal with that
always say gonna say it's nothing to do
with entity property and what happens if
i take wiki data this thing here and i
do is sub value thing on it what happens
if i do this
nothing why not because in general this
is an external identifier has no
knowledge and cannot have a knowledge of
where to get its information from why
for instance what is the canonical
service for ice be and there's no i
don't know we could pick one that's what
we have to do i mean it's like what's
the canonical service for finding image
search for doing
search on the web we pick one and change
it with a different method option we're
dealing with corner cases here we need
to deal with the main case right people
I mean but it's not gonna work if this
thing randomly returns lists and on
lists that's gonna mess things up anyway
now I don't understand how for the okay
for this case here where you're doing a
entity class search what do you think
he'll give me an example of how that
would work so control equal largest
lakes in Europe but then you have an
entity class and this one is translated
by wiki data data twelve Sparkleberry
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait this is just using our I mean
this is just using our entity our
knowledge base so I'm asking the
question how you understand what I'm
asking I think I think you're peeking
about thirty different things one of you
is speaking about the query and the
other one speaking about the result of
the query okay fine so if I take this
query right where I should be able to
get do an entity value on this I read
what do I want here I want entry in the
list okay magnificent okay
so how do I do the same thing what what
is your description of how we do the
same thing um yeah you you would say
wiki data a data of that class comma and
then the property values that you want
to extract for each member
so wait a second so this class here
you're saying
so I say wiki data data
of that class now what some property
let's say well I just want to know the
names of them how do I get their names
let's say Viki data-id the string daddy
or entity no that doesn't work yet
because it relies on property and type
alignment that hasn't reached our
production so alpha service yet because
somehow the lake and the countries end
the item has to be translated to Ricky
later so this is soon to each product
okay but but but wait a second this is a
weird construct right because what is
wiki data data you said it's something
like entity value yes but if I said
entity value so if I say entity value of
15 and then I say entity is that right
or do I say entities okay so you're
trying to model something like that
happen yeah right you could instead of
entities you could say area now that
gets the area for each member in in this
case here in right
yes no right they today does following
exactly the same model yeah it's another
property but yeah well your first area
or whatever okay so let's say just for
fun magnificent okay um and you could
decorate it in the third argument with
data set to see which area corresponds
to which entity and the same is then
possible in the key data data okay
I'm not convinced about the name wiki
data data given all of this
let's let's think about that for a
second I mean so because this is very
much modeling itself on entity value
right yes
I I kind of think wiki data value is the
right name it bothers me a lot this list
return values thing but at least with
the entity value with wiki data value
one has a fighting chance of
understanding that one could put an
entity class in the first argument also
I think the idea of wiki data value of
one of our entities I think I mean what
else can it return okay so this list
here I don't understand I mean is take
largest not supported then is that what
you're trying to tell me here that's
following directly below that list so
there's a distinction between boolean
predicates and other operators that take
that have to look at the whole list okay
but so why are you I mean we don't list
that in the case of entity value and I
think you should list it out in a big
table like this because I think it makes
it you know more obvious it makes it
more questioning which ones are not
there so to speak okay I know some way
you say missing key without an X there
so just list them out equal to unequal
to that is actually consistent because
you would say rule equal to five but you
would just say I see those are three
things okay and and in the de vikke date
so an entity value will be support any
function but in the Vicki data case it's
more restricted because we can only
support things that can be compiled to
sparker and that's why we have the
complete list of things that are
currently possible okay so is this
possible as well why don't you list that
in this table to make a distinction
between boolean operators and there's
another distinction boolean operators
you can as many as you want while
there's only support for a single take
largest or smallest
because okay okay what's this item spec
all format following options were
internet for what options for what these
are not oceans pinky those are not
options there's a the following values
for format can be get used right that's
what this is is that correct no it the
format I just explained above okay but
then we don't have string options we
don't have options which are strings yes
so we can't use those so figure out
another way to do that following options
can be given to wiki data data
altogether yes
okay so this is completely unclear what
language to use in what sense to use for
instance the labels that are embedded in
the returned external so it's it's what
to use and return values or what to use
in what you enter in return values in
wiki data search it also affects the
input so you can selectively search
through German or French labels okay so
that's a different okay okay let's go
back here what the heck is the label of
the item what does that even mean so if
you click on any of those boxes let's
say moon then you can see what it
actually means under wiki data website
so I'm going to it's a link and it goes
there yeah so moon is the label in
English and then there are the labels
and other languages
okay description is what appears
directly below
there's no directly below what what do
you mean directly below there's no
direct on the website and in this case
embedded in the tooltip
there's no tooltip showing up here over
the label
there's no tooltip showing up here this
is an issue
the front ended I encountered before
that sometimes tooltips are not showing
that tooltip shows but that's giving the
complete external identifier is that
really what we want rather than giving a
full matted thing I think we want to
formatted thing here for now this is
following entity which shows as tooltip
the input form or something like that
and they could have a better tooltip of
course well I think in this case it's
necessary because in the case of entity
we parenthesize the disambiguation stuff
that we need don't we do we do that how
do we do that formation is in the
formatting directly so the tooltip just
shows you the canonical name in the type
basically I understand this gives no
tooltip here yeah once you're reversed
until you accept it
I see okay so that's that tooltip so
that makes some sense I suppose okay
okay let's look at the discussion the
formatting over here karcz on our live
stream is is commenting on why there is
why there are multiple values yeah I
know I mean to me returning a list just
such a mess because well what do you do
if the world is a mess and you can't
figure out which part of the mess is the
clean part I understand we know this
thing is a mess that's that's why you
know that's why we do what we do um but
there are things where there really
isn't a clear arms I understand what
would we do in a case like that I mean
we don't have all the words about limits
like nu T no mas yeah um but those are
comparatively rare for us I mean what's
happening in wiki data is that all kinds
of people are throwing all kinds of
random gunk in and people don't know
which one is right might not you yeah
there might not be one that is right and
it might not be cometh it just might be
more than one for various reasons that
are good reasons in some cases well
they're surely gunk in there too for
instance the apparent magnitude of a
star you might initially think that's
just one value but it depends actually
on the pan filter that you use no of
course but that's I mean that's why we
document what we think it means right
and this is just a else
the issue is what they're doing is to
take an English name like apparent
magnitude they don't think they're
documenting I guess what it really means
anyway
look it's some now but they they I mean
Tony could give you an example if it
gives the values and you can also get
additional attributes on each of those
values that tell you which band it is
well maybe
okay who knows yes yes discuss this case
with Jeff yes that's correct
okay all right all right but what we
have is a naked list of values here hmm
don't you get consequences it's we get
data value list yeah which would at
least say what's going on I mean is it
always going to be a list it's always
going to be a list isn't it yes for
consistency I could run some queries
checking whether there's any property
that always has one value but I doubt it
all right so we should say well Larry
it's an argument to use wiki data data
Jessie on our live stream is asking why
aren't we just using entity value of
external identifier well I think this is
one good reason as there are other other
reasons you might want to set up various
functions for instance a function
repository function that is called
musicbrainz data that understands the
musicbrainz identifiers yeah so we have
a font that just be a you know entity
value of external identifiers
musicbrainz comb or whatever there be an
option to specify which knowledge base
like or from knowledge base verses wiki
data versus musicbrainz well that's but
that's but but that's why we have
external identifiers that's the wrapper
that defines that could identify it but
there could still be more than one
lookup service for that same identifier
yes oh I see I see me don't wonder
seeing the poverty the possible poverty
is thing to depend on what is earlier
even though one source one server might
support different properties than
another server is that what you're
saying yeah what a mess
so intimate the external identifier is
an identifier across all servers but
which properties you can get may depend
on which server you happen to go to
directly yeah so the identifier types
are defined abstractly and then their
various service system okay so something
analog for web image search is that
there's a method option that says what
server you're going to but then how do
you deal with auto-completion that is
specific to a service I don't know I
mean we could obviously look at what's
in the first argument but but okay let's
hold on one second okay so um as wsh on
our live stream saying shouldn't they be
a more general modifier for wiki data
entities similar to dated more general
modifier of what kind I mean I don't
think we know what the modifiers can be
I mean your modifiers are again
depending on the external service like
for archive you might want revision C of
a paper okay and you don't have a
revision in principle that could be some
limited support for dated but then wiki
data uses various state qualifiers so it
might just have a date or point in time
but it also might have a start date and
end date and which one do you mean so
yeah well I understand that this
ontology is not nearly as clean as ours
so it isn't I mean we have we have to
deal with that all right well look I'm
agreeing that wiki dated data it's
probably the right thing because it's
going to return this list I
think it should say very clearly it
returns a list of values and I think the
example you give should have a list
first example maybe doesn't have I mean
should have multiple values so it's a
little bit clearer what the heck's going
on I'll add a lot more examples ok ok
let's talk about the graphic design here
ok so I don't like the fact that in the
output it is returning with boldface is
there a reason for that
no particular reason
ok it seems like a bad idea what are we
following it's not following what we're
doing for other things bold in New York
City over there maybe no that's in the
input not the output ok yes ok you're
appointing the output before and then
Albert Einstein is in the input right ok
so what are we gonna do here we're going
to the same convention for input and
output I think that that makes sense to
do that I agree ok no I don't object to
consider that are laying on the other
side of identifies for instance
quantities or data objects now so those
form a family of identifying different
aspects of the world and they should all
be in some sense uniform next to each
other or URLs yeah and I don't think
it's right what we're doing with dates
and I thought we had a meeting set up to
fix that I don't think we want this
thing here and I think there's no reason
to have this big bold ok so if that
hasn't already been set up can we please
get a meeting set up to go over that yes
no boy it's really frustrating yes a bit
with with without a project manager it
really is a mistake um ok so get that in
please either the ILD meeting or the
design UX meeting
shall I send message about that or no I
say they did okay all right fine
neither of us or the right people to do
that but it's okay um Jesse is asking
how is the order of values in the list
determined who knows I mean it's what
the sparkle finally returned okay all
right so looking at this here this white
with the blue thing with with white
seems okay to me I mean is there any
reason why that's a bad idea anybody
want to comment on that it's kind of
similar to the formatting for date
object that's not a good reason
everything similar to the formatting for
date object I mean yeah I mean one thing
I liked was when on scroll down in your
example notebook over here there was a
point where there was some links and the
links had a different formatting oh
maybe oh sorry I was talking about the
notebook yeah right there and then this
is Bob what are we talking about here
this okay because this is a link as
opposed to this thing isn't a link this
thing you click it I mean this on the
input what are we what are we getting
here if we click that on the input it is
a link correct
oh that correct or is that not correct I
believe that's correct right that's
correct that is a link okay this is not
a link if you click this it goes back
and gives you the the the you know lets
you type it in again right yes okay so
that has to be indicated somehow and
what you've done here with this tooltip
which doesn't simply even come up for
the input which seems like a bug to me
or did it did it just come up
intermittently well it's it's a front
end thing sometimes
fine fine fine fine fine okay so the
point I'm making okay so it came up in
that case the point I'm making this is a
link right so we've got a dot dot in the
other case indicating that you can
reselect it but somehow we need
here that indicates that this is a link
possibly on hover it should bring up
some kind of greater than greater than
or something or so what how else could
we indicate that it is a link or either
if you go to this untitled to notebook I
think there was some other that was the
no chance rifle this was notebook this
one here yeah and then if you scroll we
don't have anything else in here and
there's a lot of time here okay so the
fact that there's a linking what are you
talking about there's that there's the
thing that came up for a moment there
was a link icon a hyperlink icon right
is that what you were talking about or
something different oh just a scroll
down a little bit below there is Bray at
the edge of the notebook yep right there
those URLs there's several different
yeah that's something completely
different so it's that's a war URL which
is something completely different right
but they also have the Chevron's I
understand that I understand it but
that's representing a URL this is not
its primary function is not representing
a URL okay so I think what we should do
here I don't know whether every single
one of these wants to have a link icon
well that's useful I don't know I would
actually say maybe no because if you
click around in Wikipedia that not every
link has a not a symbol next to them
maybe just the indication of this and
you click and go to a page on the web or
not for every one of these is it not the
case that there is a page on the web it
depends on the identifier type some
define a link others thought okay so
like this one here that one doesn't
appear to be a link so that one is
something different
oh that winner is a Facebook Places ID
which is not a link
okay and I don't understand that wiki ID
okay so what that's doing and that mouse
over looks crazy right with that white
blob on top of the gray background yes
so there's Mickey data-id identifying I
understand what it is I know what it is
I'm saying the format this looks wrong
yes oh good screenshot I'll include it
in the next marker or at least in the
next conversation with okay so it should
recur so is it the case that everything
identified with the wiki data ID has a
link to the web yes because 30 data idea
defines links yes that's what I thought
so the correct statement is there are
other external identifies that don't
define links and why does it say wiki
data ID as opposed to something as
opposed just wiki data given that these
things what why is it correct to have
the ID there I think that was what in
one of your earliest design notebooks
the identifier types should contained
about ID or number okay well I don't
know if that's right I mean there is a
little bit confusing since we can have a
label that isn't in fact the ID so you
think it should let us say wiki data
since it isn't the ID yeah that is like
we have this open question if you
specify a label should it place be shown
next to the extra ID over replace it I'm
sorry what do you mean so if you said in
the design notebook or the graphic
design notebook on top you see a few
examples there the actual number is
shown in addition to the label let's say
gravitation do you show the ISBN number
or not
um I would think in that case and it
bugs me so much that it's in boldface
which it shouldn't be but look wiki data
that is an entity whose label is
whatever it is so it should say just
wiki data color on whatever I think and
but then ISBN 10 is an ISBN but the fact
that there is a a book named that is a
subsidiary fact is that not true or does
I spec weed seed all the way around okay
but then it should say ISBN book : or
something because ISBN 10 is like wiki
data ID is the name for an identifier
not the name for a thing my making sense
yes
this is very weird so down here Comic
Vine for example is oh boy we're getting
ourselves tangled up here okay so the
wiki data ID is something like q77 582
or something right yes just the analog
of the ISBN but instead here we're not
showing that because we think it's kind
of stupid and irrelevant we're instead
showing the label for that wiki data
entity correct but in Comic Vine ID we
are merely showing the ID because we
don't know what there is it doesn't seem
to have a label is that correct oh we
could include the label but well does it
always have a label yes because it's
coming from the wiki data item so that
has no no no no this Comic Vine ID is an
external identifier to Comic Vine
all right thing the statement and Mickey
data is that this is the same object
identified inside a different system so
it is off the same label no I'm not
convinced about this Tony because it
might be the same object but different
people might call it different okay
depending on the service so okay but but
to know what this is okay Archon form
location boy that's the ID but I think
what we're seeing here is that there are
two different concepts one is that we
choose to use the label
now which services have labels only Wiki
data or lots of services basically most
or all I know musicbrainz has names for
their albums okay all right so then what
I feel but what is the label is a little
bit our choice fine there isn't a
canonical label in any of them I'm sorry
there isn't a canonical label I don't
think you like for the put like for the
ISBN but would naturally say the book
title is a good label but as you might
way to say the seventh book of this
person might be escalator I understand I
understand so here's a possibility if
there is a label we simply say Giant
Bomb : and then whatever the label for
this is right
hiding the 303 5 109 on the grounds that
that's not really relevant to the user
we don't have the ID there if we fail
and all we have is an ID then what we do
is we say Giant Bomb : and then in the
same font ID and then the and then the
ID so to get that terminology clear what
you see on the left in the white box is
called the typed label and you're saying
that the type label should depend on
whether
ID label is present I'm saying yes
that's what I'm saying I'm saying the
type label is always the same it's
always giantbomb : that's the type label
but then on the right we're either
giving the label always saying ID blah
if we cannot find a label so but in in
the case of DOI what would we say if the
label is available we would say DOI :
well let's take ISBN we'd say ISBN 10 :
gravitation
there's the label there's no ID and the
and the ISBN number is a separate thing
right we're merely using the ISBN
service to refer to an entity sir I'm
saying all right that seems like in some
cases we kick out the ID or number and
in others we don't no no no if we can't
find a label we fall back to saying ID
and then the ID see what I'm saying yeah
but if we have a label for a particular
book saying gravitation then how do we
get rid of the end in ISBN which stands
for number we don't it's just a service
ISBN - 10 is a service that is an
identity service for books and what
about do i how do they get rid of the I
in DOI we don't
it's DOI that is a service if there is a
service the first element here is the
entity service do i it's like like
saying HTTP um well that's a protocol
but but Tim um you see what I'm saying
it's it's like that's the service that
is providing this information okay and
then in the case of musicbrainz
we also would have either musicbrainz
artists if we have to label or
musicbrainz artist ID if you don't know
but no no no remember the ID goes on the
right-hand side of the colon gender
stamina right yes right so it's just
it is the same font as what's on the
left-hand side but is on the right-hand
side so it reads you know do ii do i :
I D blah if we didn't have a label for
the thing okay so yes we're repeating
the word I D I think that makes sense so
in an input the ID would not appear bold
it would appear that's correct it
appears the same way that it appears
right now on the left of the colon
instead as a label appears bold hmm and
it would appear bold in the output go
ahead is there another character to use
other than colon so it's not like colon
ID :
no colon off to the ID it's just on the
left side place what oh you just said it
at you answered it okay there's no
calling on the on the right side your
cell is correct okay
it's just ID in small letters and then
the then the actual ID so clarify could
you write down the example for
musicbrainz the two cases that we have I
think it's really easy I mean I
understand is it the same slovis or is
it a different service is it one service
or is it two services so there's a two
layer sing there's the organization
musicbrainz that defines the identifiers
and there multiple services that allow
you to use them okay this goes on the
left hand side of the column so the
services musicbrainz artist if it's
using that service and we're combining
that the fact that there's a base
service called musicbrainz is is you
know the idea here is it's service : and
then however we identify that entity
okay right
jesse is pointing out that this is
analogous to what happens with entities
with canonical name versus common name
um we have run out of time unfortunately
but we probably need to continue this a
bit
yeah any things to do this is it's great
but it's just there's a few details that
we should get right I mean is it really
try to make some changes maybe two three
days again okay fine but oh just just to
clarify a couple of things here I mean
in in yeah I mean this is such a mess
saying subreddit and then other ones are
ID I think this is the right thing so it
would look like external identifier and
then the service for the external
identifier and then whatever the
identifier is just like an entity but
then the print form has the thing with
the label right but that's what you're
doing here just like it works with
entity okay anyway to be continued
alright and thanks there was a few other
comments on our live stream yeah I mean
this thing with the lists is a mess and
there's some comments from Cox about
freshness which seemed interesting which
Tony should look at I don't know
that has some so and shall have renamed
the key data data to data value not do
not okay okay
in the context what what shall I do next
in terms I don't know what is ready but
yes we should cut them ready I mean
they're going in they're going we just
got some details to work out okay me and
moved him context yeah sounds good okay
good work thank you all okay see ya